okay we're hearing from people
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord i want to go next to
um let's go to matt from windsor now
windsor could be
any one of a number of states or even
canada or the uk
so when you say windsor what where are
we talking about
windsor ontario sir ah ontario very good
uh what's going on there
well you kind of caught me off guard i
wasn't expecting to get called in today
so thank you for taking my call
oh you were trying to get on though
right i mean i didn't i didn't uh
totally shock you oh no absolutely but
you were good all right very good
um i want to actually ask you before the
election
took place and joel biden was elected
president
donald trump said in several rallies
that
he wanted to implement patriotic
education and your reaction
most of the time was like woof whatever
but um i actually have cousins that live
in plymouth michigan in wayne county and
i was kind of worried at the moment
because
it seems like very much right-wing
fascist propaganda to implement
uh patriotic education this is something
you probably see in uh
nazi germany not to go that far or north
korea
so how would donald trump be able to
implement that if he were to be
reelected or could he even do that
during his time as a lame duck in office
you know i really don't think he could
um
matt because most education in the
united states
is based on state boards of education
so doc the things trump could do are
sign signing executive order directing
governors to tell
boards of education in their states to
implement what trump considers to be
patriotic
education that'd be one example this the
department of education could
make certain funds available to states
only if they implement you know it but
the point is
there's no direct way in which donald
trump would be able to do that
now that being said there's many
republican governors and state
legislatures that would be glad to put
pressure on the board of education in
their states
to start doing again whatever is being
thought of as as patriotic education but
there's really no way for donald trump
to directly do it no
right well yeah um up until the point
where
the election started i want to tell you
that don't feel so bad about what's
going in the united states i mean in
other countries we have
elections that are going on especially
here in canada we have a really bad
system
with the government that we have in
which we almost had an election a week
before your election
because of how you know scandalous and
corrupt our government actually is with
the true government
what what did they do that's corrupt so
this is going back about a couple of
months ago and this is not even that
corrupt but here in canada
you can get you can get uh corrupted you
could you could be corrupt by bribing
pizza that's actually a real story go
back and look at it
uh there's a wee charity here in canada
called the we charity and the trudeau
government gave about 750 million
dollars
around that margin to benefit schools
and other
uh organizations in canada but what
happened was
uh his mother and his brother gave
speeches at these conventions for the we
charity
and majority of the money that the trio
government spent into
the we charity would have gone to
his mother and his brother for those
speeches so wait a second hold on a
second you're saying
you're saying that his mother and
brother got the lion's share of 750
million for some speeches
pretty much yeah okay that seems
extremely hard to believe
uh so they're like billionaires you're
saying almost
well i might i'm not exactly sure
because
yeah i would double check i'm going to
kind of pause this because
i've not heard of this and the numbers
are sounding they're not passing the
sniff test matt but let's look into it
and follow up okay
okay my apologies all right very good
matt from windsor canada there we go i
want to be careful with those
numbers for sure i want to take a second
to tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 you can get
there by going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david